sports about trust issues there are
reports about a disconnect between one
of your star players in the head coach
how do you handle that well you know I
come from the oldest tree in the town
was a 3-run sack coach does is you keep
everything inside and you know no matter
what you know we live in a social media
world now everything is on social media
but you guys keep there's another furry
kick out into the corner to Lavine who
hits he's on fire hasn't missed yet
tonight you know looks at the monitor at
least once a game itself we did see some
on our telecast thinking what is stacey
talking about always does that gotta get
your guys going they leave Zach all
alone into the slaughter and that's it
if you lower the offense that was the
play the ball went inside the windows
fires hits from the corner can't get it
Levine for turret he's got a new query
been there a lot tonight it's the
smaller defenders quick shot for SAC
continuing to build on that career-high
night from three before the high
low-pass RC the a Cano diving on the
floor here's Zack building on his 37
going for 40 he hits give me the hot
sauce just the three points Levine has
40 Levine
three and eleven three-point makes what
a night forget putting a paper on social
media
6:12 three-point makes look at the guys
right there who's that guy Ryan I'll
check the app you know again playing
good defense give Zach Lavine a chance
to win it and bang bang bang give me the
hot sauce watch this now watch Archie
deaq you know just hustling and then
Zach Lavine gets the ball I don't really
know and Charlotte knew they were they
were only up to because the key if they
were playing defense like they were up
teeth what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content